pour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
saint roch a dit ce matin francis carole
bonjour bonjour avec des bruits bonjour
aux auditrices et auditeurs de marquer
les premiers
vous êtes le président du pal in my
conseil exécutif chargé du social et
vous êtes également candidats à fort de
france
est-ce que 2020 française carole ce
n'est pas l'élection ultime pour voir ce
que seront comme comme on dit ce n'est
pas en créole le vote d'hier ni ronde
manège des nuits romanes un jour où la
fenêtre de tir ne pas rater c'est un
moment important
alors on manage moi pas sauf paramètres
quoi de ma vie en fait en tout cas de ma
durée
bon j'ai 60 à 61 eur nok y en a qui sont
au pouvoir et qui dit âgées plus plus
avancées notamment dans les
municipalités
ce site c'est un moment important que
nous préparons parce que nous pensons
qu'il faut réussir le changement à fort
de france et qu'il faut le réussir
maintenant je considère que fo de france
n'est pas la propriété privée d'un parti
et qu'il ne faut pas que les étés ses ex
directeurs se contente de dire bon ça
cas où les concerts début de l'année et
on s'en tient à ça parce qu'il ya un
véritable besoin de rénovations de
transformation de la vide et que
l'équipe qui est en place nous a conduit
malheureusement allé passe et quand je
le dis je n'accuse pas une personne
je mets en cause ce système vous posez
la question que j'ai posée hier à
philippe petit qui était à votre place à
force d'accumuler des échecs
est-ce qu'on ne se décourage pas assez
quand même votre quatrième participation
aux élections
ce qu'il faut dire sur cette question
c'est que lorsqu'on s'est attaqué à la
ville de fort de france parce qu'il n'y
a pas grand monde qui dans les années 90
a osé défier la citadelle ptm je les
fais le défaire l'époque où ses airs
étaient en place à l'époque vous étiez
cncp le cncp j'avais moins de 30 ans et
je les fais et nous avons vu des auteurs
n'ont pu entrer au conseil municipal
ensuite j'ai été élu conseiller général
sur le canton le plus important canton
de fort-de-france mme canton 7 de fort
de france
ensuite j'ai été conseiller régional et
lorsque nous sommes allés aux élections
municipales de 2014
nous avons fait est ce que peu de gens
auraient réalisé à fort de france et
cela nous a conduits par la suite avoir
lors des élections territoriales environ
mille personnes qui ont porté leurs voix
sur et la partie de la liste que je
portais qui était portée globalement pas
mal ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça
veut dire que nous avançons de manière
importante à fort de france et que ceux
qui parce qu'il était facile de port de
fort de france qui sait c'est devenu
avec un petit souhait que tu te
réveilles non cette pratique est
implanté il faut le reconnaître et sur
l'a2 a demandé un travail important
qu'avec ses étés à l'issue des années et
aujourd'hui nous pensons que nous sommes
en capacité de véritablement faire
basculer à l'aps qu'est ce qui vous fait
penser que vous avez plus de chance
justement le plus gros du joueur
plusieurs éléments d'abord est ce que
l'observateur attentif qui aux gardes
comme à la vie politique évoluée en
martinique ce qu'il faut constater c'est
que depuis plus d'une décennie
le ppm n'a cessé de perdre des voix à
fort de france et l'une des raisons de
la victoire importante nous avons eu en
décembre 2015 dans le cadre des
élections territoriales
c'est le mauvais score réalisé par le
ppm à fond leur ai dit à des 46
aujourd'hui nous nous battons le ppm ça
c'est important à prendre en
considération
cela veut dire qu'il ya un changement
dans la population et que la population
de fort-de-france ne se contente plus de
dire bon on laisse comme ça parce que il
paraît que les néo gestionnaire soit
ceux du ppm et ce qui a été démenti
largement par l'histoire et plus d'une
fois et les la population était en train
de changer les jeunes les femmes les
personnes âgées il y a une véritable
mutation qui se fait et je pense que
cette mutation peut nous conduire vers
une transformation de la situation
à fort de france c'est un palm a divisé
qui va quand même
se rendre aux élections parce que marie
laurence de locke était votre co
listière en 2014 sera candidate et l
auzance éteint cette pâle dumas unis je
dis et je répète que n'importe qui dans
ce parti peut se présenter aux élections
a le droit de se présenter devant le
parti mais une fois que le parti a
choisi et qu'il a choisi la aux jo m'a
clairement nettement sans aucune
contestation est bien et il faut
s'appuyer questions d'innovation madame
de lorik cana lequel elle a fait acte de
candidature mais n'a pas reçu la mae
l'aval de la majorité du parti et par
conséquent not alone est il des
conséquences mais moi je veux pas entrer
dans ça ce sont des années avec et avec
lequel je me suis battu et ne comptez
pas sur moi pour jeter l'anathème sur
par contre ce qui est important c'est de
revenir à ce qu'il faut pour
fort-de-france aujourd'hui nous ne
venons pas simplement pour changer de
gouvernance c'est important mais surtout
sous la base de programmes sous la base
de programmes démocratique sur la base
de programmes pour essayer de redresser
les finances de la ville et pour faire
en sorte que les fouilles à l'aise mais
les fouilles à l'aise vivre mieux dans
leur vie c'est ça qui est fondamental le
programme vous allez lui présenter parce
que vous présentez votre liste la
semaine prochaine nous est attendu à
leur destin votre candidature la semaine
prochaine madame de l'or est exclu du
parti
je n'exclus personne du parti ne sont
pas une secte va donc chacun a le droit
d'avoir des ambitions je respecte ça
mais quand le parti prend une décision
débattues démocratiquement
chacun s'y plie ou si on ne veut pas s'y
plier
on peut faire autre chose le droit de
faire autre chose alors offre de france
quelle sera la stratégie du palima vous
allez soutenir d'autres candidats alors
bien entendu nous nous allons et nous
avons déjà commencé à soutenir des
candidats notamment agissons ou sépia et
je dis bien je dis bien
agissons pour ces pierres c'est à dire
agissons pour ses pieds c'est un
ensemble de personnes de personnalités
appartenant à différents horizons
politiques aient compris des gens issus
du kalimantan soutenir donc agissons
pour ces pierres et c'est ça qui sont
pour ce obtient c'est la liste notamment
soutenu par l'ancien maire
oui voilà que ceux tenus par l'ancien
maire et boxer ça comme ça mon train de
fait aujourd hui et puis nous sommes en
discussion avec une série d'autres
partis et nous avons une stratégie qui
concerne qui nous regarde un peu ce qui
se passe au diamant bien entendu de
regarder un peu ce qui se passe en la
matière d'autres jours c'était le lot en
face aux diamants vous hésitez entre qui
n'ont par exemple nous allons valider un
certain nombre de décisions je suis un
homme qui est organisée au sein de parti
le parti se réunira le moment venu et
prendra fin cet homme de décision
le lingot se tiendront les gens les
candidats en fonction de l'heure aux
orientations de ce qu'ils ont déjà faire
parce que comme un défaut des preuves de
l'implication d'un engagement dans une
direction et il faut aussi voir que le
programme qe2 l'orientation
en tout cas c'est la démarche que nous
font des prochaines semaines après celle
d'un ado non cela doit appartenir à un
parti qui certainement présenterait un
candidat contre nos efforts de phase ii
que nous sommes tous bien sympathique
l'aura fait nous ne pouvons pas et ne
plus être totalement idiot et où
lamentin au lamentin nous nous verrons
il ya des candidats qu'on a déjà entendu
comme fabrice du nom donc nous allons
analyser concrètement la situation
puisque je n'ai pas encore aujourd'hui
une décision de partie alors comment
vous analysez plus généralement ce qui
se passe au sein de la majorité à
l'assemblée
la crise qui touche le grand semblait
justement c'est une crise qui est dédié
et à plusieurs choses quand on regarde
de manière précise et rigoureuse je n'ai
pas vu parmi les gens qui se sont
démarqués de la liste que nous avons
pour autant sable je n'ai pas vu
l'expression d'une idée fondamentale
qu'est ce qui est contraire à ce que
nous avons dit c'est une querelle de
personnes je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
lèvres de l'accueil de personnes je
pense qu'il ya aussi deux des
incompréhensions et je pense aussi qu'il
ya aussi et une partie des go qui
intervient dans cette affaire ceci est à
pour ma part j'ai été élu sur une liste
pas une population qui nous a fait
confiance sous la base de programmes et
je mets en oeuvre ce programme dans le
cadre de cette liste même si je peux
avoir d appréciation critique sur tel ou
tel aspect mais ça c'est c'est ma
sensibilité aussi deux d'analysé de voir
réellement coma et appréhender les
choses il n'y a pas de divergence donc
it
logique mais c'est aujourd'hui le grand
semblait n'est pas une vaste illusion
le mime explose le rdr se prend ses
distances
est ce que ce n'est pas une illusion de
gestion jusqu'en 2021 on tient tant bien
que mal la barque
d'abord nous savions dès le départ qu'il
y avait des divergences idéologiques et
nous avons tenté de considérer d'un
soyouz depuis la base d'un programme et
c'est le programme qu'il faut appliquer
jeunes la droite patriotique je note
simplement et je vous disais que ceux
qui se sont démarqués de ma gêne je n'ai
pas vu ce quelle base idéologique il
faudra qu'on me le montre qu'un jour par
contre ce que je dis c'est que nous
avons un programme et que les éléments
du programme que nous déclinons
progressivement à travers les réunions
de l'assemblée de martek sont votées par
tous les membres de cette majorité et
j'en suis extrêmement heureux parce que
je pense qu'il faut respecter la
population
quand on demande à des gens de voter
pour une liste il faut se tenir aux
engagements que l'on a pris et donc par
conséquent cette crise elle existe mais
je pense qu'elle peut être surmontée et
que surtout nous avons l'obligation au
moins jusqu'en 2014 d'appliquer le
programme pour lequel nous avons été
élus il est évident que la configuration
d'une campagne de la campagne à 2021
cela complètement différent de ce que
nous avons connu et il y a quelques
années en 2015 paraît singulièrement ça
veut dire qu' il faudra repenser les
nuances les responsables politiques les
militants politiques ne font que penser
et aux pensées des choses et sur la base
de deux d'une expérience qui a été qui a
été menée donc ne sont pas en difficulté
de se pendre
vous serez avec mahfoud marie-jeanne en
2021 indien vous allez être ensemble que
vous allez mener votre propre liste
légère lundi jouer nous sommes engagés
je suis engagé avec nos partis dans une
campagne des municipales a donc je ne
parle que de ça pour l'instant de voir
que beaucoup de gens aient anticipé avec
qui je suis c'est l'antichambre de
de la collectivité je ne sais pas si on
travaille tout cela non je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit un tricheur
la démonstration a été donnée par
l'express que et qu'il peut y avoir
beaucoup de mails qui constitue une
liste d'accord et que là le celui qui
emporte la palme à la fin des spas est
issu de cette liste donnée à doc il faut
faire attention à cela parce que 2010
nature est prêt mais en même temps
relativement loin donc entre temps il ya
les ex municipal et ma mission
aujourd'hui c'est de faire en sorte que
cette ville change et donc je m'y engage
totalement joué suffisamment de temps
après les élections de mars 2020 pour
mettre en place les choses parce que il
y eut encore et du temps est ce qu'il y
a pas un problème au sein du camp
patriotique un problème de relève
je ne pense pas que je ne partais pas
rêver le le camp patriotique soit le cas
le plus marqué par ce questionnement il
y aura toujours de toute façon une
problématique de la relève qu'il faut
préparer et très tôt par contre ce que
je dis c'est que malheureusement parmi
beaucoup de nos jeunes ans qui met en
avant de leur jeunesse
ce que j'écris dénoncé à l'époque comme
le le jeunisme je sais que ça n'a pas
plu à beaucoup de personnes
il y à une nécessité de s'armer de
théories de capacité de réflexion
il ne s'agit pas de se révolter il ne
s'agit pas simplement et de dire qu'on
est contre il faut construire et
construire c'est connaître ces s'armer
de connaissances et de thé oui il faut
que nous ayons une génération qui a été
celle que j'ai connue à mon époque de
gens qui lisent qui essaie de comprendre
d'aller au fond des choses pour pouvoir
parler il proposé parce qu'il ne suffit
pas de se révolter sans cesse car je
vous remercie
bonne journée l écoute de nos programmes
et merci à alain livory sens qu'a dit
que vous retrouver en podcast vidéo sur
le site de martinique la première il y
aura quelques perturbations au niveau de
la distribution